It’s a tough job market out there right
now.
It feels like everyone is either being laid
off, furloughed, stuck in a dead-end position
at a job with no prospects of career advancement,
or working multiple jobs just to meet the
bills every month, as you’re slowly driven
into the ground.
If only somewhere new was hiring.
Somewhere exciting.
Somewhere where every day is an adventure
and you never truly know what you can expect.
Well, lucky for you, there is such a place.
It’s the SCP Foundation, and after a recent
high-casualty SCP-682 breach, they have plenty
of new positions open for go-getters just
like you!
That’s why we put out a post on our community
page asking for the job at the SCP Foundation
you think you’d be best at, and your reasons
for why.
And today, we’re going to evaluate your
answers, and see who’s up to the task!
Let’s go.
Javier Gomez de Lara Santos said, “I don't
know if it counts, but being on the part of
relocating safe SCP that are "rehabilitated"
such as SCP-2273 would be a very wholesome
experience to see them enjoying human company
once more ( other than doctors and security
officers ) and you could get some new extraordinary
friendships such as Alexei Belitrov had with
his psychiatrist.”
We thought we’d start this video off on
a nice wholesome one.
In any kind of Broken Veil scenario, it’s
natural that some of the nicer anomalies,
like Belitrov, the Reluctant Dimension Hopper,
and the Abdominal Planet guy would be released
back into civilian life.
Of course, to get a job helping this happen,
much like Alexei Belitrov’s psychiatrist,
you’d likely need to be qualified in social
work, psychology, or psychiatry.
But it’s probably one of the more fulfilling
jobs you can get with the Foundation.
Geologyhill123 said, “Having an MA in history,
I can see myself working as a researcher into
ancient anomalies and finding their cultural
origins.
Plotting the Aristocrats family tree - although
knowing the Habsburg lineage it's more of
a shrub - would be fascinating!
The wanderer’s library sounds like a dream
come true as well.”
Ah, now this is a fun one.
Seeing as anomalies can manifest in everything
from ancient ruins like SCP-2621 to extinct
cultures like the Daevites to twisted family
lines like The Aristocrats, taking a historical
approach to exploring SCPs is definitely a
valuable job, and one perfectly suited to
people with a background in history.
Just be careful with some of those ancient
texts.
Reading the wrong ones might lead to certain
strange mental and physical changes…
Suicunefan123 said, “I’d love to work
in virology within the foundation, specifically
writing the reports for the more math-minded
folks in the field.
In my experience, they need the help!
Ensuring reports are clear, concise, and useful
would be my ideal placement.
Dream job in reality, too…”
Virology is an undeniably useful skill for
work at the SCP Foundation, given the number
of terrifying viruses they deal with, like
the incurable contagious zombie virus, SCP-008,
the Sarkic nightmare that is SCP-610, the
Flesh that Hates, or the considerably more
technological infection, SCP-217, the Clockwork
Virus.
And hey, somebody needs to write those reports!
Drew Sklar said, “As an engineer, I feel
like doing researching and development for
containment procedures would be so interesting.
The conditions a cell has to meet vary so
much between SCPs, and each one is so strange
and interesting that it feels like a puzzle.”
Containment specialists are a vital part of
the operations of the SCP Foundation, considering
that containment is one of their core principles.
It’s an exciting and intellectually stimulating
job, but there’s also a lot of pressure
involved.
Knowing, if you don’t do your job right,
you could be responsible for a breach that
leads to a huge number of deaths for your
fellow personnel, the civilian world, and
potentially even you.
We’re sure you’ll do fine, though.
No need to stress…
Celi Phon said, “Personally, I'd want to
work in amnestics.
You don't have to interact with dangerous
anomalies, just your fellow foundation coworkers.
I doubt the job is anywhere near as insane
as research staff or mtf.
Being a foundation middle(wo)man suits me
just fine.
In with the Class A/B amnestic and out with
the cognitohazard my friends!”
That’s a great attitude!
And honestly, there are a lot of benefits
to working directly with amnestics.
Fun fact: Every time we have a video that
underperforms, we release an amnestic gas
onto our audience, and release it again later.
Who knows how many times you’ve listened
to the sentence you’re listening to right
now?
Moving on.
Tim West said, “I would go with where my
experience helps me excel at the most.
I've been working as a PSO (protective service
officer) for the Department of Homeland security
for some years now, I also worked as an armed
bouncer.
Was trained in the use of force, defensive
tactics, training with firearms, long guns,
and unarmed combat.
Also trained for bomb detection and use of
magnetometer's.
For the SCP Foundation, I would apply for
the security division.”
Well, Tim, you seem pretty much perfectly
qualified for the job.
When can you start?
No, seriously, can you start right now?
SCP-106 just got out again and we really need
a hand getting him back under control.
It’s an all-hands-on-deck situation.
Oh no, he’s coming through the wall, oh
god--
Grand-Admiral Batch said, “I’d go for
Containment Specialist, Occult Section, as
I am very well versed in the occult.
As to where I’d exceed others, probably
when it comes to rituals, as I have an interest
in them and know a lot about them, including
some, let’s say, practical experience.”
Huh…
Are we allowed to ask follow-up questions?
Because I’m now really, really curious about
your occult experience, Grand-Admiral Batch.
We’ll dispatch a field agent shortly.
Meta Man said, “I don’t really know much
about the rankings or positions in the foundation,
but if there was a job for deciding who/what
gets sent where for testing, I would do that.
I could do cross-testing as well as just having
the ability to have my worst enemies killed
by an SCP.”
See, applications like this are why we do
background checks, Meta Man.
You need to ascend to the level of O5 Council
before you can start using anomalies to belligerently
assassinate your enemies without consequences.
Doing it on any level below that is more than
likely to get you into some serious trouble
with your Site Director.
MissingNo.
Said, “I’m proficient with firearms, and
have been refurbishing weapons and doing some
pretty decent gunsmithing for parts that I
need/need fixed up for the past 10 years.
I’d have an undying loyalty to the foundation,
and maybe have a chance to work with some
of that fancy anomalous weaponry, or just
a hired MTF guard.
(The first would be fun.)
Or I could just be Dr. Bright’s newest body,
or fodder for 682.
Whatever works.”
Well, we appreciate the fact that you’re
giving yourself a wide range of options here
- Especially considering that being a vessel
for Dr. Bright or fodder for SCP-682 has a
very low barrier to entry.
But hey, considering that MTF operatives are
often killed in the line of duty, it’s likely
that a position will be open for you if you
can prove yourself.
EllisBellis13 said, “I think I would be
a researcher trying to understand anomalies
who seemingly break the laws of physics and
the universe.
I am studying math and physics and currently
doing my bachelor’s thesis on quantum bits.
By understanding the physics allowing the
anomalies to behave anomalously, we could
utilize the knowledge to develop new cool
technologies.”
We like your style, Ellis.
We need people like you on the team.
Just make sure that while developing this
new physics-bending technology, you don’t
wind up trapping yourself in the Red Reality.
But hey, at least you’d be able to keep
Dr. Scranton company.
Eric Back said, “I'd love to work with the
technical side of the whole foundation, could
be anything from IT to constructing the containments
used on SCP's.”
Yes!
Please!
You could act as a replacement for Technical
Director Rosen.
Seriously, he’s utterly unbearable.
We need to get rid of that jerk.
Krizia said, “Would probably be in MTF Mu-13
(Ghostbusters).
I have always been fascinated with the supernatural-
that, and my sensitivity to the paranormal
and seemingly paranormal would definitely
make me a valuable asset to the team.”
You seem like a great fit for the team.
We just hope that Ghost-busting makes you
feel good.
PsychoCobra Gaming said, “Having a background
in Psychiatry, I immediately go to the idea
that all of the stress and threat of constant
death would really weigh on the mind of the
employees.
I’m not sure if The Foundation has a psychiatric
department but if I could spearhead the creation
of one, then that would also give room to
climb up the hierarchy of The Foundation.
I’m sure Dr. Bright must have PTSD from
his several deaths and the 05 Council must
have some form of mental anguish from their
centuries of life.”
Oh yeah, we imagine it’d indicate that something
is very wrong if a seasoned Foundation employee
doesn’t have a little PTSD on the books.
The scary thing is, with some of the poor
folks at the SCP Foundation, them recounting
their days might give their therapists PTSD.
Stonewood Studios said, “Some kind of mechanical
engineering profession.
Just being able to observe anomalous tech
would be incredible.
I'd love to try to discern how 914 works,
or spend my days trying to understand the
functionality of the numerous remnants of
the Broken God.”
This seems like a good application of your
interests and skills.
And if you want to be even better at engineering,
why not put yourself into the SCP-914 chamber
and set it to Very Fine.
Just to see what happens, you know?
It’s a fun time.
Frank Official said, “Honestly even just
being a janitor would satisfy me, there’s
this sense of dread knowing some sort of dangerous
thing could break out at any moment.
Really does get your blood pumping.”
It’s a bold choice, honestly.
All the danger and stress of working for the
SCP Foundation, without any of the clearance,
pay, or prestige.
You’re playing 5D Chess.
Minty said, “I'd like to be part of some
kind of Foundation reintegration program where
the SCPs are taught to control their powers
and just get used to being less deadly, so
they could re-enter human society.
I just feel bad for the SCPs, being essentially
put in cages.
Some of them need a hug.
Barring that, I'd just sign up for the Serpent's
Hand.”
Considering the SCP Foundation can be a little…
Cold, towards the anomalies, you may eventually
find yourself becoming disheartened towards
the Foundation and its practices.
At this point, yes, it seems likely that allegiance
with the Serpent’s Hand would be a pretty
appealing prospect for you.
Cat and Otter said, “I would enjoy some
good old low-risk humanoids.
Have a nice chat with them, maybe go a round
of tennis with Cain, Iris, and Mr. Fish.”
It would indeed be nice to chat with some
low-risk humanoids.
Be warned about Mr. Fish, though, he’s been
known to be a little salty on occasion.
Pikeshades said, “I suppose I would like
to work as an archivist in a records room
cataloging anomalies and updating files.
I do that mostly in my IRL job, while also
turning old word document manuals into educational
videos.
So I could probably also collaborate with
doctors and researchers in how to make training
videos for new D-Classes and MFTs in how to
deal and approach certain SCPs and/or rival
organizations.”
Wait…
You want to make training and informational
videos about SCPs?
That sounds to us like you want to be our
competition.
Listen, buddy, we rule the fun, user-friendly
infographic videos about SCPs game.
You don’t want to step on our turf.
We can be very aggressive.
Gabbie said, “I think I would work in the
application and development of containment
which would be less stressful for the SCP.
My hope would be to make more of the sapient
SCPs comfortable.
Hopefully befriend a few.
I would more than likely die within the first
week.
But I hope at least I'd make someone or something
smile.”
The SCP Foundation honestly needs more people
with a humanist approach like you.
There are plenty of perfectly friendly sapient
anomalies who deserve to have a nice, comfortable
pad while they’re contained by the SCP Foundation.
Do we really want God complaining about scoliosis
because his unpleasant Foundation cot doesn’t
have enough padding?
Just make sure you exercise caution when selecting
the anomalies you decide to give the fancy
new digs to, seeing as some might use it as
a method of escape.
That being said, if we gave SCP-106 or SCP-049
a high-quality jacuzzi in each of their cells,
do you think they might chill out a little?
After all, we’ve never really tried “Making
the containment chamber too relaxing and chill
to even want to leave.”
Symphony In Blue said, “I think it would
be cool if there was a position where you
just visited/chilled with some of the friendly
scps, especially those who struggle with living
in containment.
I feel like it would be really helpful for
them and their general wellbeing/mental health
if they had someone who wasn’t explicitly
a researcher or doctor, but was rather just
somebody to talk to, to chill out with, and
to give them a little bit more normality.
Might help people be a little more comfortable
and happy in containment.”
Again, this is another pleasingly wholesome
one.
A lot of these anomalies could use a friend
to chat with.
Dr. Gears isn’t the most scintillating conversationalist.
Lolchief119 said, “I'd probably enlist in
MTF Beta-7 the "Maz Hatters" because there
was always this deep fascination about biohazard,
chemical, and radiological stuff that I’ve
had for many years now, plus there is a great
chance I get to kill zombies!
Maybe if I ask the Task force leader really
nicely, maybe I can carry a barbed wire bat
when clubbing said zombies!”
Well, deciding to club anomalous zombies to
death with a Negan-style barbed wire bat would
definitely earn you some points with other
weird, violent mavericks like Dr. Clef.
In all likelihood, though, you’d be spending
most of the time in a heavy-duty hazmat suit,
picking up dangerous waste material in the
aftermath of an anomalous attack.
Have fun!
ChocolateQuill said, “I'm going to be completely
real with y'all: I like to THINK I'd be a
high-level researcher for the foundation.
But I'd probably get demoted for wanting to
play with SCP-999 all the time.”
We appreciate your honesty.
And there are definitely worse things you
can get in trouble for doing at a Foundation
containment site, like that one Brony researcher
who…
Well, you know the story on that one.
Brodie Insch said, “Well, I'm not going
to lie, I feel that I and SCP-049 have a lot
in common (not the fact that we are both doctors
or kind of evil) but that we share a personality
and a lot of mannerisms.
If there was a job to study and interact with
a single subject that's right for me.
(I also think it would be pleasurable to learn
from SCP-049 as we share a lot of mannerisms
there is a chance I could possibly become
a "friend" of sorts and he could tell me all
about how his bag works along with the language
he writes in).”
Hey, this sounds excellent!
We think SCP-049 would be elated to have a
new friend to discuss his thoughts and theories
with.
And having someone he sees as a peer would
be a great way to keep him mellow and stop
him from breaching containment all the time.
Maybe we’ve found the solution to one of
our oldest--
Oh.
Okay.
Back to the drawing board, I guess.
Imainaba said, “Personally, I would like
to be a part of the ethics committee.
They're probably the most powerful group in
the SCP foundation besides the O5 council.
I'd be able to access knowledge that most
staff can't.
The most important part for me is that I'll
be able to make the experiments on the SCP's
and the D-class less violent.
They deserve some rights as well.”
Wow, we really are learning that a lot of
our fans are surprisingly ethical people today.
It truly warms our SCP-058s.
And it’s true, the Foundation really does
need the Ethics Committee to make sure that
these monster hunters never become monsters
themselves.
Angel Jaf Benitez said, “I'd love to work
with anomalous plants, either in the bioresearch
zone or as a member of the gardeners, I just
like plants that much, even though I know
what some plants are capable of.”
Hey, the Foundation needs plenty of botanists
for their wide variety of plant-based anomalies.
And if you like your plants to have a little
bit of flesh on the side, you can head down
to SCP-3989, the Bone Orchard, for the best
of both worlds!
Thorn Wolfy said, “I'm an animal caretaker
with a Bachelor's in zoology, so I'd likely
be some kind of cryptid keeper.
I'd do my best to ensure the more beast-like
SCPs were as comfortable as possible in their
enclosure while maintaining security and their
safety as well as the rest of the staff.
I'd likely also advocate a bit for them, try
to keep too many inhumane experiments from
happening.
No cruelty for cruelty's sake.”
Cryptid Keeper is a hell of a job title, as
long as you remember to stay safe out there.
After all, some anomalies are more dangerous
than others, and it’s often rarely the ones
you think.
But we definitely respect your commitment
to keeping things humane.
It’s always the best way to go.
Wow, what an incredible interview session
- it’s looking like the SCP Foundation is
going to have an awesome new stock of employees
on their hands once all the paperwork is through.
And thanks to this organization’s incredibly
high turnaround, we’re sure that once all
of these newbies are either nicely grizzled
or killed by an anomaly, we’ll get some
new fresh faces around here real soon.
Be sure to keep an eye on our community page
for the next chance to be a part of one of
these delightfully whacky videos!
Now go check out “How to Work at the SCP
Foundation Explained” and “Good vs Evil
- SCP Ethics Committee Orientation” for
more information on jobs and the inner workings
of the SCP Foundation!